oh it was weird you know I was I was I
was in Tottenham Court Road going to buy
an iron in Argos I live in Peckham I
don't know what I was doing in Tottenham
Court Road Shawna and I in but I
happened to be there and I saw her
across the street there was like a long
queue and the American church tree of
like people just lining up and I was
like I just went across and I was like
so much going on you guys do it and this
girl said to me I'll wear him for this
TV show and it's an open audition I
wasn't I wasn't it so you can just come
in and line up and you can get to go in
and audition I just go and I get a yeah
I get a you know and she was like yeah
have you got the script yeah so I went
to her twins in front like you know so I
lost my my number can you give me
another number and the lady is like I've
no she didn't believe me was I should
waters so she gave me a number and I've
gone back in the queue waiting in line
got inside the building and Shaheen bag
was there a casting director and she
just asked us ask me questions like way
from stuff at there and she was like oh
we're filming in Peckham Oh wicked yeah
I knew that obviously cause uh I've done
my research I just had no idea what was
gonna and then um so I left you just
asked a few questions and I left and
then I got a call saying that they
wanted me to come in and have like an
actual audition with scripts and stuff
and they were like I were gonna send it
to your email and they said to me man I
have an email account so I had to set up
a quick yahoo email got the email got
the script learnt the script went into
the to the meeting and got the job and
that was like my first TV job called
youngers on e4 and this was a few what
to me
12:13 crazy obviously from then I got
like an acting coach for a white lock
and he's like my sensei and he like
taught me the game and the craft of
acting and stuff like that so I'm still
learning to do yeah yeah comedy-wise
Robin Williams obviously Jocelyn Sen
renumber loans is a legend who else
Eddie Murphy obviously Richard Blackwood
grown of watching him yeah those guys
kind of inspired cuz they play like
especially when Williams placed so many
different characters and you can dip
into the serious and then dip my cut
into the wacky into crazy I think that's
brilliant and I just was always inspired
by that same with joseline it's weird
because writings now turning to a job it
was anything was a hobby before and I
seem to be getting into more rums now
because I've only been writing seriously
about a year really about a year I kind
of was brought on to the writing team of
the g1 print show a few years ago by
Phil Balkan Javon Prince he was like you
saw me in the part we did a pilot
together and they were like well look if
you can improvise like this then you
must be able to write and as I feel I
can't write and feels that don't worry
Sam you're well don't worry about it
we've got into the writers room for like
five six weeks and I was around like
some really cool people like poly babble
hola John McQueen AK mg and we just kind
of like created and I kind of learned
the whole writing process from that and
then after that field kind of took me on
board and said look this is how you you
know structure of scripts and stuff
around and kinda just learn how to write
I guess but I mean obviously the main
passion is the acting that's what like I
came in for him but slowly like the
writing is becoming on the same kind of
like forefront family I'm is very much
improvised you know so like we just wake
up in time and a cable just come into my
trailer in the morning and then just be
like just don't learn it don't learn the
script gonna change it and then like or
add the script like once like in the
morning once there's lunch Tom will just
be like this oh yeah you do something
there and like literally create a sketch
just because we've got the room for
another half hour but it's exciting it's
exciting it's fun you get to play and
you know try out new things and then
they just go oh this just don't get rid
of that get rid of that you know it's
wicked I mean it's I mean it's not so
because I mean feminum does have a
script we just never stick to it because
it's you know it's sketch you can make
things up whereas time wasters is
is just brilliant right in that you
wouldn't want to really improvise
because you know Daniels kind of created
this world and you're just I'm just
really happy to be in it you know
meaning I mean just just just good work
ethic no corpse in I am the worst corpse
are hmm but no just good work ethic kind
of just come in with with with an open
mind and just be ready to to take on all
everything can just be ready for it
really that's that's my main thing
because it's kind of like you go on to
say especially with sketches they're so
difficult because you're changing
characters you're doing like four
different sketches a day so like it's
hard to like keep in you know but if you
just come in prepared like prepare from
before like no this is where your
characters doing this is what use this
is his journey and you know have a
backstory so you'll kind of always have
a base to go to once you step onto set I
think I never used the declivity I did
drama before like in plays and stuff and
then and then I kind of did this play
that was a comedy it was like a mixture
of drama and comedy and then the
directors I should really think about
going into comedy and then it just it
just kind of became the route now like a
lot of you know like my journey is going
through this comedy room but definitely
I'd love to you know jump to more
dramatic roles if they're if they're out
there especially now it's like everyone
wants an age and stuff like that but
literally when when I first started
acting my friend or Enzo Kenny he said
to me that write create your own work
like literally create your own work I
think we're too worried that people
won't want to read our work because
we're not known and not you know big in
me in the industry or whatever but if
you create a brilliant piece of work try
and get it on somewhere maybe like a you
know one-woman show or somewhere like
small and just invite people like 400
and 500 people in the industry one or
two of them are
McCammon go okay we love this so it's a
start you know and and they may not but
you just continue to create your own
work because it it it exercises your
mind in it and it stops you from
thinking negative about not being
included it's just it's just it's just
it's just very helpful as an actor to
learn you know from the greats to learn
you know read all the books in and just
and just understand this industry that
we're in I mean there's so many
different styles there's so many
different you know energies that come
with this and we just have to really
maneja be a sponge and you know and I
think and I think like it helps in work
like you've you subconsciously you feel
you you can your training comes out of
you you know when when you're acting
even though it doesn't mean to and I
just think that the more you learn the
better will be for you career and for
you
so you don't go into rooms like
someone's at one time someone was
talking about a film that I hadn't seen
or you know and I was a spec if you've
seen and I'll say yeah it just to be
included in the conversation and like to
remember that bit when they are this is
that yeah I had no idea what they
weren't about so yeah just that like
watching film and going to cinema and
getting those those two for once
yeah I'd love to play Martin Luther King
right but not the serious side of him do
you mean every time I see you like like
they're my new for King biopic stay
amazing by the way like David Lee or no
one's amazing fun I want to see like the
the fun side of mine you know even if
isn't gonna have to be like a film just
like a a series or something or in a
play like just a fun side of mine he's
the king because he's he does have fun
side man you know I mean I remember I
saw him on a line on a snooker table
taking one of those backward shots and I
was like that's a cool dude like Jeremy
I would love to kind of explore that
side of him you know but yeah that's one
but the main one I've got keep yeah yeah
I'll let you know if it happens and if
it doesn't yeah you never know
[Music]